j'ai gagné vous pouvez pas comprendre
bonsoir alors on vous appelle
Monseigneur on vous appelle Jacques
comment on fait appelez-moi Jacques
Gaillot Jacques Gaillot j'ai jamais bien
admis le type de mon Seigneur ça fait un
peu pompeux et moyenâgeeux c'est lourd
hein
Jacques Gaillot alors vous connaissez
les Guignols de Canal+ vous avez déjà vu
donc votre confrère le pape qui je peux
l'appeler votre confrère
qui dit toujours alors il dit pas Évreux
évidemment
vous n'avez des relations tout à fait
courtoises
et l'évêque d'Évreux
bien sûr c'est vrai que vous portez des
chaussures Mephisto exactement
c'est une marque
attendez c'est une marque c'est quand
même pour un évêque c'est un peu étrange
non mais vous voulez dire il y a
d'autres gens qui se chaussent chez mes
fistaux j'espère peut-être dans la salle
il y en a mais alors on vous a jamais
fait la remarque on vous a jamais dit
attends Mephisto pour un évêque c'est
peut-être un peu on a trouvé que c'était
curieux
les vexes avec mes fistaux pour le
moment en tout cas ça fait une pub pour
les chaussures Mephisto extraordinaire
alors c'est vrai le le elle dit que vous
êtes peut-être perturbant parce que vous
avez une image vous avez des détracteurs
qui disent
qu'ils trouvent que des fois vous parlez
un peu trop et elle dit n'empêche que
grâce à vous c'est vrai dieu est partout
alors pour le coup écouter un évêque est
fait pour communiquer savoir communiquer
alors les évêques doivent être un petit
peu attachés de presse de l'Évangile de
Dieu alors c'est ce que c'est ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est que vous trouvez
pas Dieu a de très mauvaise attachés de
presse et que en partie c'est pour ça
que l'image de l'église paraît des fois
rébarbative et vieillotte je trouve dans
l'église on ne sait pas communiquer et
ce qui est important c'est d'aller dans
des lieux un peu étrangers à l'église
faut pas rester dans l'église pour
communiquer faut sortir oui parce que
dans l'église normalement les gens sont
d'accord avec vous avec l'église
avec les gens de l'église qui écoutent
il faut aller ailleurs passer sur
d'autres rives et ben écoutez ça tombe
bien ça tombe bien ailleurs c'est
froufrou jusqu'à 8 heures merci
Jacques Gaillot est-ce que c'est parce
que c'est le carême que vous avez
accepté de venir à froufrou pour faire
pénitence ou non je ne fais pas
pénitence au milieu de vous au contraire
j'ai une certaine joie et avec plaisir
avec plaisir est-ce que vous croyez que
Dieu a de l'humour oui heureusement
de rire toutes les semaines
en regardant ritualité en fait oui oui
chez Ramsey coup de gueule contre
l'exclusion alors là Jacques Gaillot
vous parlait d'un sujet qui est très
politique
est très polémique c'est l'immigration
dans ce livre vous parlez beaucoup de
Charles Pasqua que vous vous n'êtes pas
tendre avec parce quoi vous vous dites
c'est le rat le roi de la rafle
médiatisé du quadrillage musclé de la
course au terrorisme vrai ou supposé là
vous prenez partis quand vous dites vrai
ou supposer je suis dur parce que les
lois sont elles sont répressives et il
faut voir ce que ça donne sur le terrain
avec des étrangers des étrangers
africains en particulier malgré ben oui
alors mais pourquoi parce que c'est pas
parce quoi parce qu'à un moment vous
tous ce livre évidemment parle de la
xénophobie mais c'est quand même pas
quoi et pas s'il y a pas que lui je veux
dire c'est pas c'est pas le 20e siècle
qui découvre la xénophobie en France ce
sont des lois nouvelles qui sont
implicables depuis le 1er janvier 94 et
qui sont mises en oeuvre et qui tous les
jours touche des des immigrés c'est sûr
que on ne sait pas beaucoup parce que on
est pris par autre chose le numéro 1
aujourd'hui qui mobilise les gens c'est
le chômage ces effets dévastateurs et on
va pas se mobiliser par rapport aux
immigrés or les immigrés font partie
vraiment des exclus parmi les exclus
mais elle durcissement des lois il y a
un durcissement des lois mais par
exemple à un moment vous dites dans le
livre que il y a un type là je sais plus
qui qui se retrouvent condamnés à six
mois de prison ferme parce que il a
renvoyé une note à une femme de ménage
en disant on veut pas de gens de couleur
donc ça prouve bien que l'État français
ne cautionne pas ces histoires là
puisque le type il a pris six mois de
prison ferme donc c'est bien la preuve
qu'il y a un état qui fait attention à
ça heureusement qu'il y a quand même des
règles de justice heureusement qui
existe encore et est-ce que vous pensez
que donc depuis que la loi Pasqua alors
tout ça ça n'a plus court ça n'existe
moins il y a beaucoup de choses qui se
font qui ne se serait pas fait il y a
quelques années je peux vous dire que le
climat a bien changé depuis alors cela
dit vous parlez de Pasqua c'est vrai que
vous êtes très violent avec Pasqua mais
c'est vrai que vous vous dites à un
moment on citera que les leaders et vous
dites les odeurs de Chirac l'invasion
Giscard le seuil de tolérance de
Mitterrand le nous ne pouvons pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde de
rencard donc ils sont quand même tous
tous dans ils sont tous mouillés là
exactement il y avait une progression
depuis pas mal d'années alors maintenant
je peux vous dire que ça y va regardez
les expulsions il y a tous les jours des
expulsions
expulsait pas comme ça et maintenant on
peut le faire vers Le Mans à des lois
pour je pense toujours à cette jeune
Turque à Évreux elle met son enfant son
jeune enfant la classe maternelle
vérifiez les papiers de la mer la pâte
papier finalement ils sont pas comme il
faudrait qu'il soit on la convoque à la
police et on l'arrête on l'envoie Roissy
et hop envoyer en Turquie on a essayé de
réagir de métamnistie internationale
mais elle est déjà partie elle son
enfant est resté à Évreux
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait cet enfant
inhumain et c'est scandaleux
on va voir comment on va faire avec la
DASS avec tout ça mais voilà son enfant
quotidiens on lit aussi que vous avez
fait resto du coeur à Évreux
oui oui vous avez fait reste du curé
vous avez hébergé beaucoup de monde des
Kurdes un Guinéen c'est eux qui faisait
la cuisine
d'abord pour eux pour eux quelques fois
il m'invité faire la cuisine mais
comment c'était comment ça se passait ça
tout le monde trouver ça bien non ou pas
de
papi normalement j'aurais pas dû les
accueillir ils étaient où alors vous les
écoutez
il y avait un dortoir comment ça se
passait des des chambres oui et puis
s'organiser pour leur cuisine ils se
sentaient chez eux vous savez et des
gens qui n'étaient pas forcément de
votre
confessions
avec les autorités quand vous hébergez
des gens sans papiers
écoutez non parce que il n'oserait pas
s'attaquer à l'évêque
les mecs
Jacques Gaillot vous connaissez Laurence
alors
cette semaine justement Monseigneur je
profite de votre passage pour faire une
petite mise au point morale l'Église
nous met en garde contre nos vices bien
mais elle nous dit rien contre certaines
vertus qui au quotidien ne nous attire
que des pépins alors je vais avec vous
faire la revue ce soir de ses vertus qui
tuent alors on y va Laurence alors la
première vertu c'est la franchise quand
on dit tout haut ce qu'on pense tout bas
ça casse l'ambiance alors c'est vrai
pour les grands débats je crois que vous
en avez eu l'occasion de le constater
c'est aussi vrai pour les petites
réflexions quand par exemple une de vos
amis vous dit dis-moi franchement
qu'est-ce que tu penses de ma nouvelle
coiffure et que vous lui répondez ça
fait balais assez d'art ça casse
l'ambiance aussi donc en fait la
franchise est une vertu dangereuse
Jacques yoyo oui c'est dangereux mais
elle est très utile je crois qu'on
manque de Fran il faut quand même dire à
sa copine tu as une tête de balotellard
c'est peut-être la manière de le dire
alors il y a une autre vertu mortelle
c'est le courage il faut faire très
attention avec le courage parce que ça
attire les syndics et j'en ai fait
l'expérience à une époque où j'étais
stoïque j'ai eu un problème
d'inflammation des gencives et le
dentiste sur lequel je suis tombé ça
c'est vrai ma sectionner les gencives
sans anesthésie et je vous jure je suis
pas la seule à qui c'est arrivé regardez
les martyrs ou ça les a conduit le
courage
bon courage vertus dangereuse oui mais
il faut vivre le courage pas chez le
dentiste
alors méfiez-vous aussi de la force de
caractère ce n'est pas non plus le
placement qu'on croit elle nous donne
l'illusion qu'on peut tout supporter
moralité comme Trump veut nous quitter
on lui dit si ton bonheur est ailleurs
vas-y et vous savez ce qu'il fait et ben
il est beau petit troncs
alors que les hommes hésitent à quitter
les filles fragiles ils ont trop peur
des conséquences alors un conseil
cultiver un petit air Pommet et on vous
ménagera
je crois que c'est un cours de morale
alors si il y a une vertu tragique c'est
d'être serviable parce que non seulement
c'est pas marrant mais en plus les gens
en profitent par exemple quand vous êtes
chez vous et vous commencez à ranger
sans rallier en vous disant je leur fais
une belle maison et bien tout le monde
trouve ça normal alors il y a des petits
qui dit chic elle est bien lunée on va
pas mettre le couvert et puis à votre
homme qui vous tend une lettre en disant
dis donc pendant que tu y es tu peux pas
passer à la poste et si vous dites non
c'est le masque mais c'est ça c'est à
dire qu'on profite de la serviabilité
des gens oui ou non Jacques quand
j'étais au séminaire on m'a appris que
c'est dans le juste milieu que devait se
tenir la vertu
les femmes on est un peu exposé
et puis enfin la vertu la plus ingrate
c'est la charité parce que il y a un
coup classique vous avez un ami dans le
pétrin et vous l'aidez et vous consacrez
tous vos weekends à lui remonter le
moral et bien le jour où ça va mieux
pouf il disparaît et vous savez pourquoi
parce que vous lui rappelez à ça le
moment de sa vie alors c'est vrai alors
logiquement il faudrait aider personne
sauf que j'ai remarqué que quand on
donnait à droite on recevait à gauche
vous n'avez pas remarqué ça vous aussi
je sais pas s'il y a une droite et une
gauche ce qui est important c'est de
savoir aider et que souvent on ne sait
pas comment il faut aider les autres et
quelquefois même il faut recevoir des
autres
et tout de suite un conseil de Sophie
mesdames votre mari est un fou de
littérature il se lève avec Kant déjà
avec Proust et se couche avec
Shakespeare et le week-end il profite de
son temps libre pour feuilleter la
collection inestimable d'encyclopédie
relié cuir doré sur tranche que lui
allégé son grand-père à moins de vous
déguisant Emma Bovary vous n'avez aucune
chance qu'il lève les yeux sur vous tout
est donc perdu comment faire pour
attirer de nouveaux son attention et
bien pour arriver à mieux le comprendre
faites comme moi plongez-vous dans ces
bouquins préférés
cette semaine vous râlez contre quoi
cette semaine je vais me poser des
questions pourquoi dis maman les avions
ça fait pas pipi en l'air comme les
oiseaux
alors sinon que peuvent nous poser nos
enfants et auxquels d'ailleurs on sait
jamais quoi répondre mais nous aussi on
en a des questions des biens bêtes
parfois et puis des un peu plus
marrantes alors exemple vous êtes prié
de me répondre tous pourquoi les baskets
de chez Chanel coûtent 2750 francs et
pourquoi il y en a qui achètent ça
c'est une vraie question pourquoi
les sacs normaux c'est à dire très fin
sont devenus tellement minces qu'on peut
être sûr que l'OS de poulet va arriver à
travers le machin avant qu'on arrive au
rez-de-chaussée parce que parce que
c'est on nous arnaque c'est une question
de la vie quotidienne ça nous arrive
tous pourquoi d'un côté on demande le
bac + 8 pour taper une facture et
pourquoi une simple dactylo ne sait plus
taper une facture en sortant de l'école
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai pourquoi oui
question
pourquoi pourquoi
c'est toujours sur moi que ça tombe
d'arriver à la caisse du supermarché au
moment où la vendeuse doit changer le
rouleau de papier
ça arrive déjà
sous prétexte que certains ont décidé
d'arrêter de fumer il y a-t-il plus de
cendriers nulle part
c'est prétexte qu'il y en avait qui
voulait être au régime en supprimera les
patates c'est quand même pas normal
pourquoi quand on dit Monseigneur je
crois en Dieu c'est qu'on y croit et
quand on dit je crois qu'il va faire
beau c'est pas sûr
et puis un mystère de la langue
française mais quand même il est taille
celui-là
pourquoi la mode est-elle devenue aussi
grossesse alors quand je dis qu'elle est
grotes que ça par exemple c'est un petit
modèle de chez Jean-Paul Gaultier cette
année où la dame a une un très joli
petit sac je vous jure que j'ai le même
je vais vous le mettre il est pas cher
c'est une casserole en bandoulière
de mode qui vous émeut Jacques Gaillot
non je trouve ça drôle
pourquoi Monsieur Bayrou avait plein
d'idées formidable dans ses livres sur
la scolarité que depuis qu'il est
ministre de l'éducation nationale il n'a
plus les mêmes j'ai vu d'ailleurs
que vous avez fait gratuitement la même
réflexion à propos de Monsieur François
Léotard qui était très très virulent au
moment d'aller attaquer à Bosnie là il
était prêt à partir avec son petit sac à
dos et puis maintenant qu'il est
ministre il a l'air d'être un peu plus
prudent quand on est en fonction on
change souvent pourquoi n'y a-t-il que
les femmes jeunes riches célèbres et
maigre qui intéresse les populations
vous pouvez pas comprendre
pourquoi ça ça vous intéresse pourquoi
comme dans la Bible Dieu envoie un bébé
à la femme d'Abraham qui a quand même 80
balais tout le monde trouve ça génial et
quand ça arrive à notre voisine de
palier de 48 berges
est très âgé c'est vrai que on dirait on
trouve ça miracle et puis il y en a
plein et pourquoi comme ça je vous en
ferai de temps en temps alors histoire
d'élever un peu le débat mon cher
Jacques moi je vous appelle Jacques ne
pensez-vous pas qu'à force d'interroger
l'homme on attend tout simplement la
réponse de Dieu
Jacques Gaillot vous êtes tombés dans un
bénitier quand vous étiez petit regardez
cette photo c'est vous à 5 ans
vous aviez un petit look oui vous vous
reconnaissez effectivement je sais pas
où vous avez eu ça mais vous savez à
froufrou on discute avec les mamans et
les papas et tout ça
à 6 ans vous jouiez pas au foot vous
serviez la messe oui
bah oui c'est quand même
c'était une vocation
très précoce très très précoce alors
dans votre biographie Monseigneur des
autres ou bien ma liberté dans l'église
vous dites que vous étiez sage gentil et
sans problème et que vous n'alliez
jamais dansé
alors on peut donc pas vous demander si
vous avez été la star des boom
effectivement je peux pas vous le cacher
non vous n'avez pas été la star des boom
alors vous êtes bien rattrapé d'ailleurs
après parce que regardez on va vous voir
regardez on va vous voir un concert de
rock Jacques Gaillot regarde
sur la rue
une résurrection
[Musique]
et en plus
je sais pas où vous avez trouvé ces
photos mais on cherche qu'est-ce que
vous croyez mais c'était bien vous oui
effectivement en train de frapper avec
le pied le rythme de du rock
résurrection donc vous allez dans les
concerts de rock si vous n'alliez pas en
boum alors on m'avait dit mais il faut
venir le soir mais je dis écoute je suis
en réunion le soir dis mais c'est toute
la nuit vous venez quand vous voulez
alors après la réunion j'y allais vers
minuit 1h du matin
carrément carrément il y a de l'ambiance
que c'était ceci enfin c'est que je
ressors avec une grosse tête une grosse
tête et le lendemain je fais du stop
avec quelqu'un il me dit vous avez passé
une bonne nuit je dis oui parce que je
vous ai vu au rock cette nuit
alors c'est dommage que vous n'ayez pas
fréquenté les boom Jacques Gaillot parce
que vous n'étiez pas si mal jeune enfin
jeune pardon je dis pas que vous êtes
vieux mais quand
vous aviez 18 ans regardez-vous là vous
êtes assez fringant ma foi jeune homme
vous êtes en militaire là vous avez fait
l'armée oui vous aviez des cheveux
alors vous avez été le plus jeune évêque
de France en 1982 on vous a nommé donc à
Évreux on a retrouvé un document amateur
de cette événement de votre de votre
ordination en tant qu'évêque regardez
[Musique]
tout simplement dans la joie et la
musique
alors
je le montre ce document parce que on ne
vous voit jamais en prêtre en fait on
voit toujours comme vous êtes maintenant
Évreux en tout cas mais oui en tout cas
c'est la preuve que vous êtes prêts
comment on fait pour devenir évêque bah
oui c'est la question comment on fait on
ne fait rien
de devenir si on ne s'occupe des marches
ah oui il y a pas d'examen
ce qui est à Paris en disant le pape
vous nomme à Évreux vous appelez maman
en disant
je suis avec
je dois pas en parler ah bon je suis
tenu au secret alors combien de temps ça
dure assez longtemps ça me rendrait
peut-être pendant deux mois
j'avais des réunions particuliers avec
des femmes parfois qui sont intuitives
évidemment les femmes qui disait
Seigneur vous nous cachez quelque chose
vous n'êtes pas comme d'habitude mais
pourquoi il faut pas le dire attendez
c'est pas honteuse
et puis ensuite il faut que ça passe au
gouvernement il faut que le gouvernement
il y a un feu vert aussi quelque chose
alors enfin c'est bientôt Pâques Jacques
Gaillot alors en cadeau pour le retour
de Jésus et bien vous a préparé quelque
chose qu'on aime vraiment bien à
froufrou regarder
tout petit on me disait toujours le
petit Jésus le petit Jésus alors moi
j'ai fini pour vous voir tout de suite
je tombe sur un grand sa gueule
il y a dîner ce soir
vous le voyez devant la porte de chez
moi à travers le judas
devinez qui vient du lait ce soir qui
Jésus mais non mais si
vous voyez d'ici la Seine
ce soir pour changer et je vais
commencer par deux petites informations
la première c'est au Japon est-ce que
vous savez qu'il y avait une pénurie de
prêtres dire qu'il y a pénurie de
prêtres non
c'est même chez les mêmes les prêtres
bouddhistes c'est pareil ne veulent plus
célébrer les enterrements enfin les
funérailles donc on a inventé le prêtre
en plastique là-bas
britannique c'est tout à fait face une
info qu'il donne donc c'est un robot en
plastique qui peut réciter jusqu'à 10
prières différentes et qui clignent des
yeux et qui bouge la bouche
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça
utiliser uniquement pour les pour les
funérailles parce que j'imagine pour les
mariages pour pouvoir
est-ce que vous avez remarqué qu'en
France à part dans le jour du Seigneur
et dans Don Camillo on voit pas beaucoup
de curé à l'antenne alors à l'étranger
c'est un petit peu différent regardez ce
monsieur là c'est un prêtre et c'est une
star en Allemagne c'est une star parce
que vous pouvez le gagner
parce que si vous participez à un jeu
qui s'appelle Traum hourside qui veut
dire mariage de rêve c'est un jeu oui
bravo c'est un jeu donc auquel
participent plusieurs couples
célibataires participatif un certain
nombre d'épreuves et à la fin il en
reste un et c'est lui qui a gagné à
droite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous pensez alors qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez
original
c'est un jeu donc vous gagnez un mariage
à la télé on dit enfin en direct ça me
dit mais vous gagnez par donc c'est ce
prêtre vous marier ça peut médiatiser là
quand même hein
[Musique]
autre prêtre célèbre cette fois aux
États-Unis je sais même pas si on peut
dire prête puisqu'il s'agit d'un
télévangéliste ou d'un prédicateur vous
savez ces hommes qui prétendent faire
des miracles et qui réunissent des
salles comme Bercy et qui apostrophe les
gens alors il y en a un qui est très
célèbre qui s'appelle Jimmy wiggaert et
qui malheureusement pour lui a été
surpris en flagrant délit avec une
prostituée donc ça fait un scandale
évidemment il a tenu à faire des excuses
à la télévision en direct et il a pleuré
pleuré pleuré et il y a un jeu c'est
courageux mais il y a un publicitaire
malin qui a récupéré les images de Jimmy
swigga en train de pleurer regardez ce
qu'il en a fait
[Musique]
un commentaire Jacques Gayou qui ont du
prix surtout qu'il a doublé son audience
quand même depuis qu'il a fait ses
confessions publiques parce
qu'évidemment il a un chaud à la
télévision américaine il a doublé son
audience
vous conseillez les larmes en direct non
non je me méfie un peu de l'effet
théâtre quand même et puis j'aurais
terminé avec une femme il y a des femmes
une italienne qui est assez particulière
regardez
ses sœurs Paola
super triste de la Lazio de Rome qui
réagit en direct au milieu des
supporters sur la chaîne rail 3 tous les
dimanches regardez tous les dimanches et
les dans le sol
j'imagine une bonne soeur comme vous
devez les aimer chaque gagnant le
terrain
mais vous mais vous est-ce que vous
approuvez
[Applaudissements]
et tout de suite un conseil de Sophie
mesdames demain dimanche comme chaque
semaine vous serez encore obligé d'aller
manger l'éternel gigot haricots chez
votre belle-mère cette fois-ci vous
sentez que vos nerfs vous lâcheront et
que vous allez faire un scandale donc
tout est perdu et bien non car j'ai une
solution simple et efficace
allô belle-maman ça va oui c'est Sophie
oui dites-moi est-ce que vous avez reçu
le petit cadeau que je vous ai fait
envoyer vous venez de le recevoir oui et
bien allez-y ouvrez le
le bonheur c'est simple comme un coup de
fil merci qui merci Sophie
Jacques Gaillot vous avez vu que les
femmes s'intéressent de près à la mode
et bien comme vous le savez les
ecclésiastiques aussi alors vous par
exemple vous habillez comment pour
célébrer une messe
chasuble et voilà alors voilà autour de
la place Saint-Sulpice il se trouve que
là où nous tournons cette émission il se
trouve qu'il y a des magasins
spécialisés dans les accessoires de la
religion et notamment dans les avis
ecclésiastique alors il y en a très
jolie comme vous le voyez sur ces pages
de catalogue alors ça ce sont des
modèles de chasuble alors on lit en
dessous existe en tout coloris
liturgique ça veut dire quoi coloris
liturgique
des périodes liturgiques par exemple en
ce moment nous sommes en Carême c'est du
violet oui d'accord mais donc est-ce
qu'il y a des coloris pas liturgiques
il y a du vert il y a le
jaune doré il y a le blanc il y a un peu
toutes les couleurs alors des chasubles
il y en a très jolis vous remarquerez
que celle-ci est d'inspiration très
mexicaine assez pop c'est
mexicain alors dans ce catalogue il y a
des habits et des mannequins comme à La
Redoute sauf que là ils sont censés être
des curés alors je vous montre deux
mannequins curés je sais pas je sais pas
si ce sont de vrais prêtres mais ça se
pourrait alors on remarque je le dis
sans perfidique ils n'ont pas choisi des
sosies de wernerschrider
alors je dis ça parce qu'on a le
sentiment qu'après être n'a pas le droit
d'être beau
Jacques Gaillot d'avoir de beaux yeux
d'ailleurs à ce propos permettait de
vous dire chargé de caillot que vous
avez de beaux yeux
je suppose si Jérôme revont vous pouvez
faire un très gros plan sur vos
magnifiques yeux bleus je suppose qu'on
vous l'a déjà dit exactement alors je
reviens à mon catalogue outre les
chasubles on y voit des aubes de prêtres
avec capuchon dominicain là par exemple
alors j'ai vu que j'avoue que je m'y
perds un peu vous avez tous ces habits
là dans votre garde-robe
je précise que les habits liturgiques ne
coûtent pas tous le même prix et non il
y a ceux qui ont de la dentelle et ceux
qui n'en n'ont pas et avec la dentelle
c'est plus cher vous êtes très dentelle
vous ne faites pas dans la dentelle
alors je précise que ben oui que le prix
d'une aube de prêtres simple comme
celle-ci regardez est de 685 francs et
celle là avec les petits froufrous en
dentelle en bas et aux manches et bien
elle va chercher dans les 983 francs
alors il fait 10 ans
mais c'est pour les coquets celle-là
elle est beaucoup plus cher alors mais
il y a des prêtres coquets
oui en tout cas c'est sûr oui mais c'est
donc c'est pas un péché la coquetterie
alors la soutane par exemple alors ce
qu'on voit là et bien la soutane alors
là il y a pas du tout de dentelle et ben
c'est cher une soutane
oui je vois quand une histoire quand
j'étais nommé avec des copains pourtant
qui sont pas pratiquants qui ont voulu
m'acheter une soutache non surtout pas
dépenser de l'argent de soutane mais ils
ont est à Paris ils ont dit on t'offre
une soutane et je crois qu'ils l'ont
payé je sais pas si c'était 1500 francs
parce que ça fait longtemps c'est 2321
francs celles-ci c'est quand même le
prix d'une veste chez Irié Joël
tu préfères peut-être la veste chez
guerrier
alors dites donc je ne sais pas donner
d'être prêtre et c'est pas donné ça
coûte ça coûte du pognon alors à part ça
il y a les habits civils alors vous vous
habillez très souvent vous voit bien si
vous vous habillez ou dans des magasins
normaux
des soldes en particulier
alors dans les magasins spécialisés il y
a aussi des blousons regardez ce blouson
il est pas mignon ce blouson de curé
alors c'est vrai qu'on se demande un peu
quelle différence hier entre les
blousons de nos maris mais bon alors
dans le même genre vous avez aussi des
chaussettes de curé regardez c'est le
dans le catalogue c'est dans le cas
alors vous chaussez-vous portez des
chaussettes tout le monde comme tout le
monde et puis il y a des chemises
d'écoles des gilets alors vous
remarquerez que ce mannequin prêtre fume
regardez en conclusion je dirais que ça
revient très cher d'être un prêtre à la
page voilà
alors Monseigneur Gayo vous n'échapperez
pas à la règle en venant à froufrou tous
les gens ont une épreuve et donc je vais
vous demander de regagner votre loge
s'il vous plaît le temps que nous
préparions un petit peu le plateau
alors au revoir
voilà
tout va bien tout va bien bon et bien
écoutez on vous retrouve dans quelques
instants je suis très angoissé non il y
a pas de quoi vous allez voir à tout de
suite
alors le coup de coeur de cette semaine
c'est un spécial copinage avoué et
assumer à froufrou on vous dit ce qu'on
aime et il se trouve qu'on aime Joël
Gorron
ça tombe bien parce qu'elle sort un
bouquin aux éditions Michel Lafont alors
ça s'appelle évidemment je râle pour
vous d'un voyons c'est du Goron craché
alors du Goron c'est quoi ou un style
drôle
c'est du commun des mortels c'est ça
gros c'est du nous c'est à dire nous pas
les vedettes de télé non nous les femmes
les mères les copines les consommatrices
en gros c'est le cri de guerre des nanas
normale et normalement excédé partout
c'est à dire comme on est dans la vie
alors en fait c'est quoi c'est c'est les
chroniques de ces chroniques de from
front c'est toutes les histoires que
j'ai raconté et voilà bon voilà c'est
comme ça voilà et alors elle raconte
bien la vie bah oui la vie alors je
précise pour ceux qui ne le savent pas
qu'une Goron ça la ramène comme ça mais
qu'en vrai c'est un petit coeur sensible
comme tout alors
un formidable comme elle faut que ça
vive alors faites un geste
c'est un geste c'est 99 ans prix maximum
une autre idée de lecture pour vous que
vous voyez bien qu'on est pas sectaire à
froufrou c'est l'excellente initiative
des édictions Dupuis des éditions du
puits pardon la BD est en fait alors
vous pourrez trouver un million de BD à
10 francs dans la France entière du 6 au
30 avril je le dis et puis autre
initiative de lecture intéressante les
éditions Librio rééditent des grands
classiques de la littérature ça va de
Kafka à Maupassant qu'on adore en
passant par Shakespeare et ça aussi ça
coûte 10 francs c'est pas 10 francs à 10
francs les livres à 10 francs c'est pas
cher voilà mon dernier coup de coeur
c'est pour les Aristochats ça ressort en
salle le 30 mars et nous on les aime
bien parce qu'ils sont drôles et puis en
plus dedans il y a une jument qui
s'appelle
est-ce que vous êtes prêts
on vous a donc fait enfiler une très
belle blouse et on vous prie de venir
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau s'il vous
plaît
alors
chaque caillou dans une semaine alors je
vous explique dans une semaine c'est
Pâques alors on voudrait on voudrait
simplement que vous nous expliquiez ce
que c'est que Pâques elle en veut pas de
sermon on veut que vous le fassiez il
paraît que vous soutenez une association
de tagueurs c'est un peu vite dit enfin
effectivement j'ai fait un peu de taxe
sur les murs des tags ou des graffitis
je fais un peu du tag oui
ils ont dit on arrangera ça après alors
écoutez nous on a fait venir un jeune
graffeur professionnel c'est Grégoire
Monet voilà alors lui
on est Grégoire le tag le tag et le et
le graffiti ça n'a rien à voir c'est
toujours la même famille mais c'est vrai
que ça change l'évolution alors
gras nous graffer ou comment on dit
faire un dessin
c'est rapide faire un graffiti sur le
thème de Pâques allez-y Grégoire va
faire autant vous vous avez un bout de
mur il a un bout de mur allez c'est
parti et on ne copie pas Jacques Gaillot
on ne copie pas sur son camarade
qu'est-ce que c'est Jacques Gaillot ah
mais attendez
mais c'est pas si bête que ça
[Musique]
ça ne marche pas très bien ces trucs là
votre camarade lui et ça marche très
bien
ça marche très
je pensais je pensais pas que c'était
jaune mais ça fait rien
alors pas de panique vous avez les
couleurs des bouchons sur les
bombinettes
voilà du vert
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça c'est
un petit pouce
c'est des petits arbres
le graffiti c'est voilà
il a pris un peu sur mon truc là
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien c'est bien Grégoire
continuer Grégoire il va nous expliquer
en quoi c'est Pâques allez-y
pas que c'est l'hymne à la vie
alors le soleil ça fait rester en vie
tout et pourquoi il est rouge
vous savez quand le soleil se couche
c'est beau
la vie et Grégoire c'est quoi votre
destin
je connais pas mais je sais pas si c'est
Jésus qui monte qui descend alors donc
c'est pour ça et je voulais marquer
Pâques P un P la tête qui remplace le a
là pour k pour pas que voilà
je rappelle que vous avez sorti un livre
qui s'appelle coup de gueule contre
l'exclusion l'année de tous les dangers
alors c'est aux éditions Ramsay j'engage
vivement tous les gens qui sont contre
l'exclusion et contre la xénophobie à le
lire c'est un plaidoyer donc contre un
coup de gueule voilà prouve c'est fini
on vous laisse tous les deux à vos
graffitis amusez-vous bien salut à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]